[Music]
this storm is a mammoth storm it has
caused untold damage and suffering
the entire country has been decimated
I have never seen anything like this
before massive Gus goes
another storm is on the way
you want Britain to do everything is
power to assist us and assist us now
[Applause]
the eye of Omir early in the week
satellites had been tracking its
progress since it formed at the end of
August as it gathered strength and
swelled in size in the Atlantic it's mid
hurricane season Harvey had already
dumped months of rainfall in a few hours
on Texas Houston was submerged surely
nothing could be worse than this but
Harvey was a category 4 hurricane on
Tuesday Irma was upgraded to the maximum
category 5 status a hurricane hunter
plane from America's National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration flew
through it it recorded sustained winds
of more than 185 miles per hour
[Music]
viewed from the International Space
Station it soon became clear it wasn't
just the biggest storm of the year but
one of the biggest ever
[Music]
Florida had several days to plan for the
worst and for hundreds of thousands of
people that meant getting out of the
danger zone but for most people living
on small islands further east in the
Caribbean there could be no escape take
shelter and hope for the best was the
only option Barbuda is one of the
smaller and lesser-known of the
crescent-shaped leeward islands just to
the north of its larger neighbor Antigua
it was the first to feel the full force
of Emma we just did a flyover and I have
to tell you my heart sunk and this has
been one of the worst days of my life so
I know how you must feel as Bob units
the entire country has been decimated I
have never seen anything like this
before
around 2000 people live here
90% of homes were damaged half of them
are no longer habitable
[Music]
you had a situation where containers
40-foot containers actually lifted up to
about a hundred yards so from where they
were originally located I mean the
island and perhaps the Caribbean has
never experienced anything like this a
two-year-old child was killed as her
family fled their battered home during
the height of the storm
[Music]
[Music]
one formula for in this situation it was
not
and now Barbuda faces another battering
hurricane Jose is heading this way
as Omer pushed westwards the French
territories of st. Barths and San Martin
were next in its sights
as well as the British overseas
territory of Anguilla
[Music]
the island of st. Maarten is divided
between Dutch and French administration
soon after irma deported a Dutch
military helicopter was able to provide
aerial views of the devastation it had
left behind
[Music]
there are fatalities on both sides of
the island almost all homes were damaged
there is no power and no running water a
state of emergency has been declared the
Dutch and French governments quickly
mobilized troops to deploy to the
affected islands but the British
government appeared to react more slowly
a minister talked of sending experts to
help Anguilla relies on Britain for
defence and security massive bus scams
Islanders were unimpressed tell us that
you're sending us expert without a
timeframe and in the context where
everyone knew in advance that this was
going to be the largest of the Atlantic
is so unacceptable the Royal Fleet
Auxiliary shipments BAE was diverted to
the area but more was needed the
government defended its response our
immediate concern is ensuring the
support is there and every effort is
being made as these hurricanes are
devastating these islands but at the
cobra today I were also ensured that a
piece of work was being put in place
already started on long-term planning
what is what will be the reconstruction
needs for these islands in the future
what support will they need and what can
we give Engineers restored power to
Anguilla's only hospital and reinforced
shelters in preparation for hurricane
Jose six tons of emergency aid was also
unloaded 24 hours later transport planes
at RAF Brize Norton were being loaded
with supplies and personnel we're going
to have aid from different shelters
medics medical supplies we have about
200 War Marines who are turning out we
have engineers so we have all the basics
of essential support that will allow us
to get that into the region as quickly
as possible and then deliver it to where
it's most needed this is where some of
it is headed the British Virgin Islands
are to the north of their American run
neighbours and were more directly in the
path
the storm officials there had to
broadcast emergency radio messages to
the loss of power and communications
doesn't just terrify those who've
endured the storm relatives and friends
of expats and tourists fear the worst if
they cannot contact their loved ones
they're probably safe and well but until
telephone lines and mobile signals are
restored no one knows for sure the
larger islands in the region
Puerto Rico Dominican Republic and Haiti
were all lashed by rain and wind but
avoided the kind of catastrophic damage
seen elsewhere these nations have
regularly endured destructive hurricanes
throughout history but the leaders of
some Caribbean nations are blaming
climate change from making it worse we
are clearly suffering from the effects
of climate change and that is an issue
that we have to add it a to ensure that
is less pollution less probability and
pollutions by larger countries
understanding that smaller countries in
the Caribbean in the Pacific that we
literally suffering the consequences of
climate change
whatever the cause of the trend over the
past 20 years has seen hurricanes become
more intense and powerful and if that
continues there will be worse to come in
the future obviously you can't just
attribute one storm to global warming
but a warmer sea does certainly
contribute to a more powerful storm we
haven't done the research yet on Harvey
last week or indeed Urmi yet a tribute
can't so you can't actually attribute it
to global warming but one thing that
global warming does mean is that we will
see warmer seas and you need that sea
surface temperatures to be over a
certain amount so there are suggestions
that a warmer atmosphere will make more
severe storms as mo continues its
week-long journey across the Caribbean
the Bahamas is the latest nation to be
hit shops in the capital Nassau were
boarded up in preparation and some more
remote low-lying islands have been
evacuated because of the risk of being
swamped by the storm surge but oma did
weaken it was downgraded to a category 4
but it remains an extremely destructive
storm and it's on its way to Florida
hurricane Irma continues to be a threat
that is going to devastate the United
States and in either Florida or some of
the southeastern states this is a
complex forecast anybody from Alabama to
North Carolina should be watching this
storm very closely the forecast and and
the direct impacts of this storm have
yet to be determined because one it's a
very powerful storm but the nature of
the curve and that forecast after 72
hours is going to be the key to see who
gets the worst impacts here it's not a
question of if Florida's going to be
impacted it's a question of how bad
Florida is going to be impacted which
means that Emma will land right at the
front door of the president Donald
Trump's mar-a-lago residence is closed
and shuttered the president will be in
Washington well away from the storm but
closely monitoring a hurricane which has
already affected tens of millions of
people and will be felt by many more in
coming days this is a storm of
absolutely historic destructive
potential I asked everyone in the
storm's path to be vigilant and to heed
all recommendations from government
officials and law enforcement
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]